yeah welcome to this video round six of
the sim field cup yeah the round after
the red state was an interesting route
and we're going to look at all of the
games as we already did in them in the
videos before the two videos before
however unfortunately in the on paper
main game of that round ronnian with
white against Magnus Carlsen we didn't
have such an interesting game this is
why I'm starting with that okay spoiling
a little bit here but well you'd see
that it wasn't really that interesting
we had an English opening here c-45
Iranian is switching around between c4d
for sometimes 93 and here c-45 is
something that was certainly part of of
the preparation Carlton has played this
reversed dragon um setup I mean like is
it black ass who chooses the setup and
this is why displaying the dragon
reverse but black is choosing to play d5
that makes it a dragon um so he had
played this before so it could have been
part of the preparation this for example
on cards not only had played last year
and in rapid abandon in Brazil um the
whole idea is very solid for black um
then dragon has a reputation of being a
super aggressive opening at you would
think that with the tempo up it would be
a very very exciting for white but the
thing is that with their tempo up why
does actually discouraging black from
those sharp setups that we often see
with colors reversed where long castles
is happening and we have opposite side
castles and this is not happening here
both sides have canceled short and now
we get more of a positional better
something that Wyatt can also play
against the dragon that is called the
classical very
and it's not supposed to be troubling
black so much in fact the extra 10 per
year for wide makes it very often
comfortable for whites to play not
without them and or not with a much risk
or anything but it is not a line that
promises wide so much as I can tell from
own experience I've tried to play this
with white quite quite a bit over the
years and I never really found them a
way forward to do something concrete
yeah 92 this line is some a bit a bit
rare yeah but has been played it's not
it's not a new idea white quite often
wants to focus it's nice to maybe jump
on to c5 um Carlton here however has an
opportunity that he did take training of
that bishop I think that's almost
invariably a good at DM against this
fianchetto said absa that is a strong
bishop on g2 let's get rid of it yeah
aronian captured that now and went queen
bee three um yeah it it doesn't lead to
much but what really doesn't have
something something great that you can
do if night be three for example trying
to go to c5 black and just centralized
and I mean he doesn't have a bad pc in
this position on a b5 move you're always
have this 94 jump and this is some
happening in the game something
comparable quite often there would be a
structure where white takes on d4 and
after it takes black has ideas against
it too we see that in the game I think
already this is kind of equal it's not
really i'm leading to anything great
that dead white hands IAM queen bee
three was played and carson just
retreated keeping everything nicely
centralized the Queen on a tree was
pretty much on its own and well you
cannot do something like that them yeah
that
be a good idea stumbling into that
tactic yeah so black it went back right
a 3 a 5 that's also typical maneuver
they're attacking those pawns white has
to go forward and now 94 I already
mentioned that idea in this structure
black always has these ideas against ito
and this is very often on the the
counter play that he needs some because
this is also potentially week and
sometimes deform and in our game
actually after a form we had Queen d5
and this is forcing what happens now
it's it's really if why does now not
shaking he did take on d5 if he is not
doing that let's say he keeps the Queen
on the board then black play something
simple like this and he has ideas like
c65 at the right moment and still f5
Black has a space advantage he shouldn't
forget that in the center um so why this
is taking now which is basically ending
the game but he didn't really have a
great alternative Teague's Bishop takes
why is it ending the game yeah white is
a bone up and black has to get it back
which means he has to play a five now
the night moves cheeks and drew kichu it
was a bit quick to terms server delay
yeah now this is traded and we now get
basically everything traded rookie one
check and Bishop before again if you
don't do the simplification here that
supplying to both sides then you are
really really worse so sometimes you
they get into these situations that way
you really cannot avoid any more that
everything gets traded down and again
here we have those simplifications takes
takes everything gets taken the future
and here they already called it a day as
this absolutely nothing to play for yeah
that was as I said a rather unexcited
game it's sometimes really happens that
that players on that level and that's
standing okay if you'd like to win that
sets certainly true but they don't want
to risk something something great and
aronian played a safe opening with
rented a safe open was one c4 and we got
to the situation where it was difficult
to avoid those simplifications it's a
bit of a shame to watch but um now
Sheamus wrong word but we would like to
see something something more spectacular
but it just happens sometimes that
nothing is going on ok the next game I'm
going to check is Giri are not let me
have a sloth defense here with e3 the
slowest lab as if it's normally caught
and now uh non-gm comes up with a slight
surprise plays Bishop g4 which is not
the main move Bishop and high vassor
whelming main move on the top level
Bishop g4 ever is of course um I'm
totally ok there's nothing particularly
wrong with it the interesting thing is
said after age 3 now vichy retreated to
age 5 this is really not very common um
normally if black plays Bishop reform
and he's taking and continues like that
setting up this typical yeah there's
typical central formation with the
bishop traded which is of course very
very young sound and it's very healthy
setup however white is given the bishop
pair without any particular um
compensation blacks compensation is as
flexibility maybe but long term he
always has to worry a little bit dead
white can do something with the bishops
he plead bishop age five and ultimately
this would also not preserve the bishop
but it leads to something different as
what has to play if you really wants to
play for something he has to play the
movie for
and this is what give you did on yeah
either here on let's say after Knight c3
g6 then G for its late leads to
something comparable but that's the only
way forward for ydm to have to break
that pin and this is what happened this
will net what the bishop anyway but in
this particular situation white has
played with G form which gives us a
distinct flavor also black of course has
currently something on the age five yeah
that's all very very normal and now move
that I mean I'm not an expert on that
line but I was surprised that 92 and was
played here but I mean then the night is
really completely wrong there you wanted
on c3 but 93 um black can really take
him it's not it's not apparent what
whites compensation is here Black is
able to keep that porn if attacked so
I'm probably whites didn't have much
choice to play this it's not that bad
it's just that my first impression was
wow really that that looks passive but
it's not it's not a huge deal we have
the g5 and he pushes seven white is
playing for a four anyway and their form
that doesn't really matter that the
night is sometimes bad on d 2 because it
clocks up the development but here why
it gets an F or before yeah I note that
Allen played an early night f80 am
interesting and g5 that idea is that he
was able to do this yeah the night now
has a very decent looking place now on
g6 um white has the two bishops that's
good but he has to worry about those
weaknesses all the time Bishop e3 and
castles was played and now Giri went d5
and still played very quickly I didn't
didn't know that because well I watched
some of the broadcast but um I was more
focused on the other games to be honest
they were a bit more um
they were sharper um the id-5 played
very quickly the thing is that after
that we have from some some
simplifications going on and I'm not
really sure if that leads to anything
maybe it was more more interesting that
say for white to keep the tension a
little bit longer and play and play a
preparatory move I'm not quite sure what
it should be like queen bee three maybe
a move like that Quincy seven Andrew
create and blackest is really solid it's
not in a bed in a bad spot IAM i just
wonder if this is maybe I'm resolving
things a little bit too early especially
considering that he aguirre played d6
and I mean that's not bad just trades
off lots of things and I think at the
end there's probably not much not much
happening um here again you could have
played something something slow look see
one nor or a three I mean some some move
to and maybe Bishop before is a bit
awkward right because you you need to
cover define okay let's say a three yeah
one of those slowish moves um maybe this
is more interesting I mean White has the
bishops and he can still try for
something with d6 later it doesn't need
to play it right away it seems that the
six I mean that's not an illogical move
it opens up the diagonal and everything
but if we check this now yeah it feels
like I'm black is okay here with b6
Bishop to c5 no it's that seems to be
completely okay and after night f4 white
really has no big choice he has to take
that night it's just too strong and this
is a very obvious draw already yeah
because there is nothing that white can
do he heads to birds opposite colored
bishops and the only slide hope is as it
is often is putting pressure on one of
those pawns in some sorry i meant f2 or
f7 and I've white would have
like rook d7 Bishop g5 putting pressure
down but the thing is it all evaporates
very quickly if Brooke 27 here asrock 28
yeah if you want to keep it on the 7th
like it some just doing this here Bishop
d5 is not possible and we have the
default can even ask if blankets maybe
even more comfortable here so there's
really nothing to be done here and they
had this traded and here rook to e7 is
ending every kind of hope for for
something in meant i think they didn't
trade yeah and and agree to a draw so
somewhat somewhat unspectacular game
again here um maybe the key really was
that um this is very straightforward
play with d5 and later t6 maybe that was
really releasing the tension a little
bit too early if you wanted to fight him
it was maybe better to keep keep pieces
on with a three and only later trying to
do something something more concrete but
Jung I understand in opening up the
position for the bishop pair just look
very logical but in this case it seems
to only lead to two simplifications and
ultimately m22 nothing much okay so
let's have a look at the next game this
would be what Sheila graph MBL rose to
power off and we get a Berlin slight
surprise to part of place that opening
it's not that he never does it but he's
not a regular practitioner of it and
quite I mean he's a very aggressive
player so the Berlin doesn't really seem
like a natural fit um ok we get the
endgame Jan yeah not d3 this time and we
actually follow for a while the game
Caruana comes in
that was played in the first leg of that
grandchester this and this was played in
the car on a console game that black
setup is not the most on the most common
one yeah they nowadays more prefer
things with age five instead of age six
and 97 in general black some setup or
setups quite amazed to to look at him
that he can play everything basically F
from Bishop to d7 to e7 or whatever IM
black has many setups which makes
studying the whole thing rather
confusing in the kawana Carson game that
I mentioned on Kara wanna went be three
at one a nice game yeah this moment and
we are now deviates in place night to t4
and after some thought yet sir it wasn't
all just the preparation we follow a
stem game quite quite quite a bit but it
seems that it wasn't was it all prep
yeah 94 rather logical move white wants
to use the f porn at some point ninety
six and four and Bishop c5 yeah this is
also something that is typically happens
quite often what black wants to do is
quite often is set up a light squared
blockade and therefore you're often are
willing to give up your best bishop pair
there on deform to make sure that f5 is
not happening there should be three and
now h5 this is all part of the plan
trying to freeze the White King side
points now g4 is not possible anymore 94
takes
rook takes and then aged 4 yeah that was
the blockade that I was talking about
now those squares are very nicely am
protected routine one and now Bishop f5
or looking very very standard yeah and
now mvl comes up with a really strong
move I think and I had a bit of a hard
time when I looked at the game to
determine and we really am I wasn't
successful I have to tell you right away
and if this is really really bad for
black or just very uncomfortable because
you can question and black so all set up
a little bit if this is some if this is
really really strong I mean it is strong
in a practical game quite quite clearly
i'm talking about the movie 6 i should
put it on the board um move that it's um
it's always some going to be awkward to
meet her because blacks what strategy
was based around the fact or the idea
the fact is wrong we just see it as an
effect that white cannot play those
moves like e6 f5 and he does anyway
always uncomfortable to face what is the
point of them move black can take it
with with the bishop and the pawn um he
took it with the bishop and we're going
to look at this later um f cheeks it
seems i mean the computers prefer that
move actually um and I couldn't really
determine what the best continuation is
the most obvious move is probably 95
looking at that weakness but after be 6
9 a-6 and rook c8 it is not entirely
clear how much of an advantage this is
this is rather complicated route d7 and
then e 5 is coming and she takes King
evade and as weird as this looks it
doesn't seem to be totally clear yeah
this is kind of hanging
and yeah white can try ft x g5 in this
position 95
and if it goes back if I can I check
that start with that I can just go here
not much is happening and after the
rukon coming back black can probably
even consider to take on c2 mm-hmm it
looks rather cheeky but it's maybe
possible um this was 95 after FTX white
also has 95 that's also quite annoying
and the night has a good post there and
black still is rather uncoordinated and
always remember you cannot castle and
it's not easy for him here too to
connect rooks or give give both rooks
are useful role whether it's a certain
to eternal problem in the boolean
endgame the rooks have to play somehow
um it's not quite clear how black is
supposed to play that may be 97 as an
idea to go here but white has c4 I think
white has some pressure here as well and
he had pressure in the game definitely
so I'm not really sure maybe that
deadline here needs to need some
improvement esox seems to be awkward for
black at least as I said in a practical
game it leads to a very tough defense
with very little chances of getting
something good yeah Bishop cheeks was
played ultimately but Apollo 95 yeah and
now we see that white is some attacking
two to two things and black has a hard
time to keep that beep horn if he goes
be six white will take oops come on take
and play rue 57 and this is just not
good yeah it's just not good one key
line is this 97 takes Knight here and
takes him and here why this is probably
just just winning the game at least he's
a porn up for absolutely nothing yeah
then tomorrow also we cannot go back and
this is a check this is also pretty
awful threatening with this and
this yeah he went to Luke Luke age five
and now white took em b7 it's funny that
this actually was plated sorry that b6
um line that was played in the Czar's
shah rukh soo lava so it's not a
analysis will actually played in a game
for what about that I had looked at that
game up it was played but they both
weren't aware of that yeah as you see
from the time they both played that
independently and not just reproducing
something yeah well Luke eight Shrive
was played and white tu compu seven and
this is just really awkward this
position those points are eternally week
NC 5 is a great square for white rube
t5b 3 keeping the tension a little bit
and improving the structure will be 8
and why it took now yeah it looks maybe
I'm a bit strange to straighten these
pawns but the thing is that the
remaining structure the structure now on
the board is also hugely favorable for
white again a 77 there all week this
night is not well positioned and the
bishop is not good at its kind of it
powers up there are a number of problems
with blacks position you played c6 and
now we see a nice a nice maneuver and
then sometimes chances is simple and you
see a weakness your tacit and here we go
rook d4f 187 is an attackable weakness
and why this is reaching for that yeah
unfortunately black really has no other
move then who Cade I mean this is
terrible if you have to play that you
know that's not not your day but ok yeah
you cannot just give up the porn if what
is allowed to check the a porn he will
do so and then much all the way through
to a 8 and we see how awful this is a
nice move now is c4 yeah a very good
technical move that maybe a week a
technical player would struggle yeah why
would you want to place you for is that
a good idea it is yeah
because if black takes this is what
happened in the game we see that c6 is
is easier than to pressure from from
Sephora put pressure on and in general
what we had you have some pressure on d5
and if we get to take on d5 that is also
weakness that isolated pawn that is
easier to attack than the c6 pawn the c6
point is not so easy to reach while that
pawn on d5 you can sometimes even even
reach we linking yeah black joke rook
takes Bishop f5 and now it be seven yeah
threatening 96 so just a simple threat
but really awkward to meet King here
check and 96 yeah we are approaching a
winning position territory black and
cannot defend this f5 hangs f7 hangs you
went to be one and white takes on f7 and
there are a number of ways now I Blitzer
it's a matter of choosing one winning
continuation but but mvl does a good job
Vienna nothing he doesn't allow anything
or something like that f5 pushing that
night away and now here it takes a seven
and the bishop took check yeah and this
is this is overwhelming as rook b7 as a
threat and sometimes you get to f4 with
your bishop rube d8 and you just took
that yeah that's simple solution rook t6
Bishop f4 we lose the whole look yeah
very nice display here by maxim Rashida
graph two part of Willem didn't have any
any chance in that game it looked it
looked rather rather one-sided e6 was a
really nice idea and an idea that it
seems he found over the board um it's
hard to tell um how black should improve
earlier on or even later after that yeah
because it starts with an
position edited it went downhill step by
step by step I also couldn't see a clear
way to move on pond and blacks play it
was just very very uncomfortable to play
and it feels like a very deserved
victory this also what the part of said
he was very nice in the postgame
interview Arrington not everybody even
does such an interview after losing two
games in a row but she was very um was
very friendly and said I welcome mvl
played a good game and everything ok so
next game to check his grief shock
kawana both players not having a great
event especially caruana some tournament
isn't isn't what he what is certainly
expected or what he wanted to do ok so
we got a Queens gambit declined the same
line that karana hadn't played earlier
in the event in the first round against
Aronian & goo show goes for c5 the move
that grabs spatium and yeah nowadays
it's what they play on the top level and
this is no surprise i when i studied
this line in 2011 it i think it was
making that part of my black repertoire
i was thinking that g5 is actually the
only move that that that can give white
anything if he plays a 3 org c1 or
something like that like it's going to
c5 and he will equalize this it's it's
sometimes maybe an absolute nibble for
white but it's really really really
really really little so c5 is the way to
go and term yeah nowadays say they all
play it night before that it's a special
move by koala is play that a number of
times already and yeah it's interesting
it's the it's the sharpest move it seems
and a bit more interesting in comparison
to let's say night h5 or c6 this is what
I always play 36 um 94 is interesting
because it frees up F porn and later
onji porn and we see what happens a
three that's a bit of a mysterious move
by visual but it was part of his
preparation as he said um unfortunately
I'm in the postgame interview he was cut
a little bit short and it would have
been interesting to learn some points of
the move because it's not quite quite
clear what it's doing yeah compared to
Luke see one yeah okay black took it
here and then went to see six Queen a
four and now g5f I've yeah that is the
aggressive point behind Lex 94 mph he
removes that night and frees up his
pawns there on the kingside an
interesting position that by the way at
first is evaluated as good for black bag
by the engine is also a great shock said
in the post game interview but he felt
that it wasn't clear at all and after
agree it's just it just it's just very
very sharp it seems that black is fine
but it's very very sharp age 3 was
played f1 putting that bishop out of
business for the moment on h2 and now he
five yeah breaking in the center very
aggressive play here with black biker
wanna out of this very solid opening but
it is ok he can really he can really do
that there's nothing wrong with what
he's doing Bishop e2 'if 192 bag we see
that greece shock follows his prepping
he really was some was going for this
and interestingly enough now quran i
decided to sacrifice on c5 and yeah
after that black has a good position I
mean not sure if he's really better but
he has a good position and he m and
quite curious really shocked really hit
aimed for that position recourse and I
mean I would feel rather uncomfortable
playing this but okay he's got strong
nerves so what is happening here black
has sacrificed the piece for two pawns
and while his pawns are
really aggressively placed here if we
look at this year that's really it's
really something and as pressure only
three everything looks nice one problem
whatever that's not going to go away for
blankets that his king is exposed
especially that move g5 is something
that in many situations you would rather
yeah I'd like to take back at play g5
back to g7 which fortunately it's not
possible and chest um what happens now
yeah Bishop decides to cancel after a
longer thing um what time what else was
there and he had one opportunity i mean
one one option let's say there was
interesting he could have just given
that piece back immediately yeah
something like that that definitely was
an option and think i think from from my
perspective something that I maybe would
have considered um it's equal material
now and blacks King is unsafe on the
other hand the bishop on h2 is not doing
that much and white structure is also
not ideal but I would have been very
afraid of those pawns so castling is a
brave decision Knight takes e4 was I
mean it was also messy to take that it
felt it felt simpler that same yeah okay
b5 maybe a questionable move what else
yeah black could have taken only three
and it's not quite clear what you didn't
like about that after this and white has
to take only for he has to give the
piece back in that way um well there's
nothing else really if you move that
night black is I'm doing something like
this check and this looks terrible idea
he's a yes to had to give up four pawns
for the peace and black spots here
amazing yeah so he has to basically
after checking yes to play 94 there's no
other move
and this seems to be really okay for
black yeah um black gum but take it of
course nothing else um and now yeah
white will probably have to capture only
three there's no big alternative there
Bishop cheeks check teenage one this is
entirely unclear blankets two pawns up
but this King is very very very insecure
if you just imagine that Queen taking
here Bishop coming here Bishop coming
here I mean it that can end up badly
really quickly maybe it is better for
black to not take only three but to play
Bishop is six just put out this biz
Bishop to consolidate one important
point is that if why it takes on before
we have 25 and this is really nice for
black it is equal material for the
moment but white has a hard time to keep
the e3 porn if Y Jake's for example we
can be sure III was that possible by the
way check why not huh that looks that
looks fine yap like as a pawn up here
and after Queens traded and things are
rather clear it's not really maybe he
didn't see but should be six I don't
know I don't know f takes he looks
normal he went b5 and said and the
position is interesting after that it's
not that black is losing but in
comparison it seems better to take only
3 we need seven there now it was too
late to take as an idea for was possible
so Queenie seven king age one yeah it's
hard to do without that move and now be
should be six I mean black definitely
has compensation for that piece it's
it's it's it's not it it's not clear if
it is enough really it's it's a very
very tricky position to play and we see
that Kara wanna was already down to one
to have an hour
note that they don't have increment and
29 minutes for 21 moves is not as not
particularly much if you consider how
yeah how sharp and how unconventional
this position is um now we shall played
an interesting move um it wasn't
necessary to play that move I guess
there were other options but it I think
it was probably strongly played 84 yeah
checking the Queen side with a takes be
five being the the main threat the
curious thing about that movies it
allows that default push which Kara
wanna played and now he went back to the
one so interesting concept yet basically
has lured this point forward and it
turns out that them now even more
advanced pawns with d3 this is what
happened that they are rather vulnerable
if black wouldn't have done that d3 what
would have happened taking here 194 it's
not a good idea that looks good for
white taking here is different but the
same evaluation that doesn't look right
so what else is there he basically has
to I mean this is something but again an
idea for now here the bishop is you free
that looks particularly bad so d3 and
now Bishop g4 yeah it was interesting to
listen to be shocked in the post game
conference press conference our
interview press conf contents is wrong
they didn't interview them and he say he
fed he felt that essentially felt like
that is winning now um which is a strong
statement but maybe that's not so far
off I mean winning is mia is a bit much
but the thing is the pawns are now
somewhat stopped they are fixed and we
shouldn't forget if you play that many
pawn moves and most of koalas moves have
been foremost then quite often your king
is suffering if put you put our g5 f5f
for blacks king is very much open while
whites king is save on each one and this
can be the problem that that can hit you
if you push that many pawns in front of
your king it turns out that white really
quickly now drums up an attack against
the king so yeah maybe grease shop is
right after all I mean take stakes in 93
yeah and we see that how White's pieces
are activated if black moves that Bishop
now 94 looks really nice so he took on a
3 2 1 C 525 yeah II to wasn't helping
white can take care because this is
hanging with check um yeah Quincy feiven
and why it took here yeah things have
clarified a little bit and now we see
that this Bishop is out in the open and
this will spell trouble without the Jeep
on being home on g7 yeah note that this
position if black somehow could play g5
to g7 he would be if totally okay yeah
it's really important to understand
Queen takes III rookie one Queen f2 went
back to have 722 we are looking at this
and this is really the problem all the
weaknesses Queen g6 and now we need move
rook a 6 yeah not a nice move to face on
your charm trouble yet black cheeks then
Cree g5 shatters win this is hanging
with check and this is going to be even
worse so this had to be played and yeah
not we should play it and this movement
rubbing and rubbing it in a little bit
yeah you cannot take on a 6 berth now he
also could have played this one also was
strong attacking here and if black takes
the rook Queen g5 King f8 Queen g5
we'll win it's a bit it's a bit much
what even has the time sometimes to play
King age two and then put the bishop out
the problem with this line is that ruki
aid bishop h5 is winning and this is not
so easy to see beforehand the idea is
that this is a big threat if black
Marchesa spawns then Queen c6 for
example is strong the rook has no
squares and say it goes here check and
check in here and again where are you
going yeah King here is green jan 5 it's
it this is unnecessarily complicated and
look a one group e to a one is some is
simply ok taken now Andrew k7 yeah this
is reliably stopped black cannot play
you three with age 6 Tehran I was really
really down on time the clock see are
not entirely precise but it is that area
yeah and good shock takes take some time
here he repeated once note that there
are no increments so it's not that
kawana Sunday got a minute gifted it's
really not the case um and now Jack he
gave the check and went to Queen a one
and this is the decider Queen a three
check is the big idea checkmating and
here Kara wanna while trying to play the
move before he lost on time I think it's
part of the of the game still he played
it so it is a it is a move but it was
some um it happened together yeah the
move was played and he overstepped the
time um got a nice win for Greece shock
in a in a very very complicated and
sharp game and certainly yeah further
indication that this is not really
kiwanis event Jen it's not to hear an
interesting opening with that p
sacrifice
c5 but ultimately I'm the position
proved to be very tricky with the with
the deficits and in King safety okay now
to the to the final game to cover Wesley
so against nakamura um this is the the
main game and therefore the last game
that I'm going to find your game that
I'm going to feature um it's not such a
long game but right it's actually in
terms of moves that is longer than a
thought actually okay let's let's get
going um most of this it starts with a
long theoretical line we have a king's
indian classical with Bishop e3 this is
the so-called caution or variation of
the Kings Indian classical quarrel has
some really am put is um or leaf but
what is the right expression down there
left his footprints or so on that on
that liner has played it played it so
often and with with excellent results
this is essentially um one of the
sharpest things that white can play
against the Kings Indian in the
classical variation the thing is that
Bishop e3 and then putting it on f2 that
puts the bishop on the most aggressive
square for the Queen side but at the
same time also gives black some time f
what was happening with the tempo and
often if black pushes the Jeep on he
will win another temple on that Bishop
on f 2 so this is an accelerator this
kind of setup white is very quick on the
queenside but black is also very quick
on the King side which makes it
basically a guarantee for interesting
games um 93 was is played by him by
Wesley so now I think that move in in
recent years has some made a slight come
back it was really believed to be not
particularly great for for some years
but it has been played a bit as I said
recently
i'm not a huge expert on that line
because with white I always avoided that
I never liked black having this attack
so never never allowed it 96 and c5 this
is one point of 93 you get in c5 good
game Knight f6 Luke f7 all those are
fairly normal looking moose the look on
f7 is a king's indian standard maneuver
protecting on c7 and allowing bishop f8
possibly Luke g7 King edge one now that
is often necessary in the long run to
give this bishop asked where if g43 hits
I'm sorry and was entirely wrong button
h5 and now he took on d6 sold it in they
both played very very quickly so it was
part of preparation um in this position
there was a game last year between she
rose and back row in the bow 2014 it's
probably the European club card european
club cup which are also played in yet
not be five from here it was interesting
g-form takes takes Quincy to g3 and now
a sheer of very cold blood lee plate 97
an interesting move attacking here and
leaving that bishop here on pre um
letter interesting interesting structure
him black took it traded here on 167
this knocks you want and it seems that
white was white was in decent shape here
yeah he later won that game yeah white
people will pick up that point at some
point and he is really dominating on the
sea far 95 was an interesting
alternative it wasn't played by Wesley
so it took on d6 and now when I b5 yeah
a six and now back to a three that all
was part of the preparation and the
thing is that after b5 now which is
stopping that night
this is the main idea played rooks e6
and to be honest it's a bit it's a bit
mysterious what what drew the white
player to that setup it was clearly part
of the preparation yeah we spent like
two and a half minutes to reach that um
because it just it's not they're
promising and if you go for it um I mean
then the next moves by Nakamura are very
very normal there's nothing particularly
surprising about them and after that
white really quickly gets into trouble
so it's a bit mysterious if you play and
play this in two and a half minutes I
think you should have some something
more up your sleeve you cannot just stop
it i know it sounds a bit strange
because you already have to any moves on
the board but if you play 1 d4 against
nakamura you know the king's indian is
one of the main things okay he can play
the Dutch or whatever but the King zinan
is one of his main openings and if you
play the classical I mean this exactly
will be on the board so it's a bit
mysterious what so is doing now after
that I mean what you really cannot do
when maybe this is what he did he was
entirely relying on on some engine
analysis because the computers are
notoriously useless and Kings Indian
positions say because they tend to over
evaluate and whites position quite a bit
Nakamura in the postgame interview said
he suspected that the computers give
what a really substantial advantage he
already which is funny enough not the
case yeah the computers give widest
slider edge only which also surprises me
quite often they would evaluate some
Kings Indian positions as winning for
white when in fact things are totally
unclear flex attack is strong it just
takes time sometimes to hit but when it
hits it hits with full force yeah g4
what else could have expected that and
now Queens to that was already with some
time spent Queen F a drupe c1 yeah
that's nice but what exactly happens on
the sea far it's really not clear and I
know it sounds at some
harsh but after the next movie place
looks is seven now I think after that
white has huge problems in keeping a
playable game I mean you know this is
this is kind of a lot yeah the whole
attacking force there on the Kings side
and if you have all your stuff you on
the queenside basically not doing much
that can be can be a problem it seems a
better here to play on the queenside
immediately and just ignore that this
book is attacked which is happening
quite often in the classical Kings
Indian white can think of a move like
this attacking a six and just let black
take and it's not clear that black
should take but let's say it does and
you capture with the pawn and now you
have a dangerous passer and you have
sometimes the idea to do something with
that night on before which is otherwise
it really it somewhat stupid looking
piece and this seems entirely unclear
this position and I would have
completely understand why it's a play if
he was aiming for this yeah because this
feels entirely as I said unclear and
very complicated to play and the
computer actually um evaluates the
position as rock roughly equal
interestingly enough this is probably
what he should have done um but by the
way Nakamura does not necessarily need
to take he can consider to give up that
a six porn for his attack yeah g3 for
example is a move that fits into the
position quite nicely yeah the point
being that if white grabs here then h4
yeah this is accelerating the tech
immensely and very questionable if that
is something for what yeah black will
attack with all these pieces you'll note
that this is sometimes coming this is
coming nice jumping it's just a while
okay this is what happened to Luke c7
and the bishop age six yeah setting up
for g3 bishop you want because g3 was
too awkward and now aged for now this is
the this
the moments that made me stop playing
the classical Kings Indian with wide at
least the main line here because you
just feel like an some kind of tidal
wave is rushing over you isn't that well
now it looks it looks rather rather
rather difficult and after the next move
that saw is playing he's definitely
losing he really is losing but it's
difficult to give him any advice well
what what is it that he should do it
took on g4 and we'd see what happens
after that but I don't really know what
to suggest yeah it's it's really
difficult let's say I'm playing a move
that is probably not making much sense
but I just want to want to see what
happens if something right does
something like that blackboard play age
three and completely open up the the
King side yeah ticks and then g3 yeah
note how quickly now all pieces come
into play a black has jumps route g7
he's attacking with everything that he
has and this is also winning and the
computer is already giving a wind
flatout win for black the tech is just
far too strong yeah okay Wesley so took
on g4 f3 then what's the idea she takes
and 90-84 that's very strong opens up
this the F file um yeah now White has a
couple of moves that you can check and
he took a while I he took 30 minutes and
played rugby one and it seems that he
can already not you cannot save himself
anymore there's no way out to get it get
a playable position um it seems the
relatively best try was route 67 trying
to get that look away there but black
has better option than Luke takes t7 of
course after which here like this white
is fine he has better options and the
the main option I mean options is wrong
yes one move that is strong you can take
on f3
you're just smashing through and this is
a win really um the threat is rook f1 if
white is playing let's say something
like that or any other move that is not
changing much Jen this is going to win
yeah this is a major Nate and the king g
2 a 3 is also a nice way to win tix on a
three and no root g one is very nice
yeah that cuts off the king a king has
no squares and there is no way out of
this really know and what did I have in
them online Bishop d2 already very
desperate but then Bishop f4 is the key
thing Queen age 6 made impossible
impossible to stop for example on after
Bishop f4 you can give that check check
night x check check check mate and one
of many mates that that might happen
here in this in this game so rook t7
Rooke f3 um this is better check this is
better I'm sorry and this is just played
this is just very easy sorry Queen g2
Queen g2 is that is the Baron tix and
now White has the desperate rook to e1
but this is still on keeping this is key
that keeps asking questions if black now
it takes Queenie fourth is fine for
white yeah that is not convincing at all
but black has a better move here h3 is
strong and probably winning probably but
Bishop d2 is exceptionally strong really
really great move the point is that
after Bishop t2 and it's maybe have no
big alternative then night f-4s hitting
and these two nights I mean this is just
amazingly strong yeah what is why it's
supposed to do the greenest queen is
hanging
yep yep check check check and wince the
house really the absolute house yeah
here oops King here okay we'll even end
in a mate yeah it's it's it's really
awkward to him rook takes t7 was was
tougher though and any other moves the
move set was suggested by alejandro
ramirez in his note was 95 that is them
a bit tougher and one point is that this
is chang even good for white um but
black has some 22 replies that give him
an advantage Bishop g4 does and he takes
and also also does which is also given
by Ramirez it's not saying that this
saves white but um it was that Lisa
avoids this kind of thing I'm sorry Mike
will take her first it had leads the
voids in immediate immediate made but
it's ultimately ultimately also also
also losing its already beyond saving
this is what was played by my soul and
nakamura took on a three of course it's
um the most obvious move but it is
strong it is strong if white takes it
jetix Chang is going to be quick end of
the game or Queen to Bishop g4 that's
even stronger than I mean then it's not
even stronger it is stronger than taking
one on the one because screen g6 was was
in here also black wins yeah so rook g7
was played look everyone check check
yeah what cannot take again because of
checkmate and King g2 yeah now Nakamura
played the move Bishop e3 which is it is
a strong move and wins the game so no in
no way this is to be M criticized but
yet and even
and even them more static way to
continue and it's just going to look at
h3 check was strong King takes a
ceremony move and now the amazing
pointers rook f2 it's a bit of a
mysterious move what is what is the
point of it yeah and we really have to
check what happens after the captures
but let's start first with 90s yeah this
is easy check checkmate made into cute
made if Bishop takes black has and this
is this is a great one and Queen f2 yeah
that's an amazing move that the point is
that black is threatening all kinds of
checkmate sir first of all night g5 made
and if it takes white eggs check
checkmate this is really a absolute
beauty of a checkmater isn't that nice
the King on h4 is getting mated by the
Knights and the bishop that's really
beautiful it's really a bit unfortunate
that they're still in a a trope yeah it
would be great without the edge rook
those three minor pieces killing the
White King but there is it just it's
just great um yeah and after after Luke
F to invite cannot take as we said and
well what is he supposed to play yes no
books yeah if he I mean on a passer
let's say check check check check mate
is one of the mates it can happen dad
would have been so beautiful to have
that made with the three minor pieces
but a Nakamura had seen Bishop e3 and he
was checking be here and it's winning so
you don't look for from 1pm in the
postgame interview he said he had seen
some kind of ideas that that were
related to rook f2n Queen f2 but he
couldn't really make them work so he
went but should be three yeah Bishop g3
doesn't look particularly great but
there was nothing ready to do if white
takes the rook chatting age three king
cakes check checkmate is a pretty quick
end to the game yeah Bishop g3 and tooks
tooks what kind of English instead he
took it rook takes everyone check check
on age four and now queen age six yeah
black is the rook down but it doesn't
matter it's checkmate end and with
multiple with multiple moves g5 force
play now bye bye so what happened after
this check check check Nate and made one
of many nice checkmates ok when g5 check
and this is strong threatening again
made night if to covering age three
check check check yeah and now I'm black
had a couple of ways to checkmate but he
chose a nice one check check jegs check
double check checkmate and mate yeah so
William played it out and he allowed
them made on the board to happen which I
thought was very nice touch and this is
not done that often in in professional
chess but I think it it's good yeah if
you see ok you're getting check made in
a couple of moves and it it's just a
nice picture on the board why not allow
it yeah I mean it's very nice for the
crowd to see that final final picture
appearing on the board and it also if he
would have resigned a couple of moves
earlier when you could have safely done
so like 10 moves ago then I mean you
have to then explain to people I you
know I'm getting checkmated and so on
well let's just play it out enter and be
be gracious to your opponent to to to
allow that because when nakamura played
a great game here
it was really nice um it feels that
somehow the preparation of the white
player here was off the physician thank
God wasn't all that great and it seems
that maybe he didn't have that much of
an experience with with this line and
very fat a little bit like that there
was some statements issued them by the
other players and it felt that it was a
bit of an anti positional performance
there on what he did on the queenside um
yeah I don't know sometimes the
preparation is just off you think you
have a good position and over the board
to see oh wow this is getting dangerous
and I think he really quickly realized
when when we were around here at age
four and so on how dangerous this is I
mean around TM it's probably very
difficult very difficult to to hold if
if possible at all ok I hope you enjoyed
coverage of the six round I think
interesting round three tens decisive
games the drawers weren't that
interesting but three out of five is a
pretty good pretty good ratio of good
games okay I'll be back tomorrow with
coverage around seven thanks for
watching